こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです
みなさん　ジェンガ　したことありますか？
僕もジェンガ
大好きです
そんなジェンガを今から たくみ とやろうと思うんですけども
正直
ジェンガで僕
負ける気
しません
ということで今日はある程度のハンデを背負った状態で
ジェンガのバトルを
彼に申し込もうと思うんだけども
そのハンデとしてこちらを準備しました
MUSCLE（マッスル）
はいこちら
EMS　マッスルフィットネス
これ何がすごいかというと
こちら
貼るだけ簡単筋肉トレーニングをサポート
こうパットを貼ることによって
電気刺激が体に発して
1個につき4枚のシートがついてる
付けたらたらダメな場所がちゃんとあるので
そこだけ気を付けて使いましょう
顔とか頭とか陰部とか・・・
（笑）
何も面白くないね
これだけのルールを守ってつけていきましょう
これを全部体に貼った状態で
彼にばれずに
体中にこれを全部貼って
ジェンガ大会で僕が勝とうと思います
では貼っていきましょう
MUSCLE（マッスル）
全部出し終わりました
というわけでここには25個の
電気マッサージ機がある
で1つにつき
4つのパットがついている
25×4で
俺の体100か所に
電気を流すことが可能でござる
あぁ・・・「ござる」っておかしいな
なので今から
この体25か所にパットを貼って
電気を流した状態で
ジェンガを勝とうと思う
もちろん
バレずにな
ではいこう
MUSCLE（マッスル）
とりあえず貼っていきます
とりあえず腕でしょ
ん～
これやばいんじゃね？これ
ワンチャン死ぬぜ？
いえぇぇ
やべえわこれ多分　5分くらい使うだけで腹筋シックスパックだよ
（笑）
はい
というわけで
体100か所に
電気が流れるパットをつけ終わりました
MUSCLE（マッスル）
背中もちゃんとついてるので
完璧にハンデを背負ったまま
ジェンガで俺は勝つ
電源をつけていきます
リモコンがすごい邪魔になるので
僕はショルダーバッグを背負ったまま戦います
マックスだ！
アッアッアッやばい
痛い！
あ～すごい　でも気持ちいい
全然気持ちいいですね
あ～いいですね
あ～いいですいいです
なんか
これぐらいのハンデならあってもいいかなってぐらいなんですけど
あ～すごいなんか
ちょちょちょちょ・・・
やばいやばいやばいやばい
あ～すごいすごいっすね
うわぁぁ
いいなぁ
やっぱこれぐらいのハンデがないとね
やばいやばいやばいやばい
やばいやばい痛い！痛い！
OKです！
全部ついたので
戦ってきます
では！
は：よぉ！たくみ！
は：久しぶり！
は：よっしゃぁ
は：じゃあジェンガ大会やるか！
たくみ：やるか！
は：よしゃぁ
2人：最初はグージャンケンポン
2人：あいこでしょ
た：じゃあ俺からだ
は：はい！
た：いくぜ！
は：負けたくねぇな
は：よっしゃぁ俺の番か
は：いくぜ！
は：勝て・・・まってまって
は：背中取って背中取って
は：やばい！本当やばい！本当やばい！
は：痛い！痛い！
た：痛い痛い痛い痛い！
は：やばいやばい！
は：はぁはぁはぁはぁ
た：取ってるときバチバチ来たんだけど
は：くそぉ
は：負けっちゃった